look at this beauty rob dyrdek
skateboard superstar it's rob dyrdek
I feel incredible you look incredible
no that's you're flattering me right now
I got the team up with Smosh and Ubisoft
for the watchdog's released the video
gained obviously a super anticipated
really amazing game and sort of like an
open-world where the main character with
Aiden is this phone right and the
ability to do all these hacks and
different stuff so Smosh wrote this
really cool script about what would
happen if I got the phone power we
created a funny little take on warding
off all the bad guys and shooting some
criminals down with some of the tennis
ball guns it was a really cool project
he's out there trying to make right what
was happened to his family his wife and
daughter were killed right so he's
trying to get back out there to make it
right and if my wife and daughter which
I don't have
was killed and someone said you know
this phone can hack everything in the
city and you can track those people down
and probably put a lot of money in their
bank account and get revenge
they made an identical or a very
particular set of skills skills I have
acquired over a very long career
I can't speak on that for a fact but it
feels like you want it feels like it
feels like somebody read some weird
document that's like hey this is
something we got to look out for in the
future I'm on my big things at Street
League skateboarding which is my
professional skateboarding League just
did a big deal with Fox Sports for the
new home of that Rob big day we're
excited about this around here Fox
Sports 1 SLS coming to the network my
first television show is airing with the
new season of ridiculous and it's called
snack-off and I'm just in the middle of
producing a ton of shows and just
continuing to scale brands and media
skateboard is a hobby you don't
skateboard for fun you skateboard for
life you know it's just a part of what
you do and once you do it you do it
forever
I know I'm gonna beat you so I'm trying
to like gauge like how shitty it should
be - you know I'll tell you what I think
I think if you lose you gotta jump off
that ledge into that foam pit that's
fair enough let's go
I just lost that Rob Dyrdek fantasy
basketball NMR stuff I go into the foam
pit